(applause)
- You got to meet Elsa.
- Yay!
- Yes. Wait.
(applause)
- So, this is the greatest
part I learned about you.
You're famous for going viral
in a video when you were like three.
You were three.
I mean my little boy's three.
He don't do much.
(laughter)
I'm just sayin'.
He don't do much.
Let's check out this viral video, y'all.
- [Mom] What'd you say?
- I look like Serena Williams.
- How?
- Because I just shoot it
and it goes way up in the air and bam.
I was just like Serena Williams.
(laughing)
- Side eye.
The side eye is my favorite.
(applause)
- So, now you're on 'Mixed-ish.'
- Yes.
- So, tell us about it.
Do you love doing it?
- I love 'Mixed-ish.'
- You love it.
You are hilarious in that clip.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
- My God. You are adorable.
Is it fun working with Tracee Ellis Ross?
She was on here recently.
- Oh
my gosh.
(laughter)
It's so fun.
She's like the best person on Earth.
She's super funny, too.
- She is really funny.
And she speaks French and all
these different languages.
I was like 'Wait. What?'
Yeah, she was really
really cool on this show.
But what is this show about?
- Well, 'Mixed-ish' is about
a family who moves from
a commune to a cul-de-sac.
And
they
are dealing with some big issues.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Look at you.
Just telling the story.
(mumbles)
So, 'Mixed-ish' is
actually set in the 80s.
82 is my year.
80s were good.
But what have you learned about the 80s?
Since you're little and not from then.
- I have learned about VHS tapes.
(laughter)
- Yes.
- I guess it's something
where you stick it in the T.V.
- Totally And it plays a video thing.
- Stick it in.
- Yeah.
I don't know.
And then I've learned about
the big hair they have.
- Yeah. Aquanet.
- Yeah. Big hair. I had big hair.
- Yeah. Hair spray. Yes.
- Definitely.
- Hey, higher the hair, the closer to God.
That's what we say in Texas.
(laughter)
I'm just sayin'.